pareil je voulais dit cécile je pense
que c'est la plus grande star qu'on ait
reçu dans tpm vraiment donc merci
mireille on a reçu plein de stars a même
avoué nationale ouais voilà mais
mireille ccc au dessus on est d'accord
ou pas alors je vous le dis on va faire
un petit jeu rapide donc mireille je
voulais 10 et une carrière
exceptionnelle et on avait envie de la
comparer avec d'autres
immense artiste j'allais devoir me
répondre en disant si la réponse est
mireille ou un autre artiste d'accord
vous jouez avec nous chez vous celui qui
me donnera le plus de bonnes réponses
désignera le chroniqueur qui va devoir
se déguiser en colombie jusqu'à la fin
de l'émission pour bien sûr nos match
très tranquille quoi c'est un de mes
titres préférés
attention alors comme on n'a pas trouvé
de costumes de colombes ce sera un
oiseau mon sait pas encore lequel vous
inquiétez pas faire à votre avis qui de
mireille mathieu ou de michel sardou a
commencé sa carrière en premier oui oui
c'est bien c'est me right way mireille a
commencé sa carrière le 21 novembre 1965
ce n'est pas un télé crochet en 65 au
jeu de la chance au 21 novembre
c'est un peu l'ancêtre de the voice de
oui c'est ce qu'il y avait une chose
extraordinaire c'est que c'était le
public qui téléphonaient et c'est pas la
même chose pour moi personnellement je
le public mais un art is his grasp ruby
non ces jeux enfin je pense que c'est il
faut tout d'abord son jury qui qui
sélectionne qui sélectionne et
personnellement je trouve parfois les
candidates on ne voit supérieur à
certains juristes cij bull permettait on
l'a votre première télé mairie à où il
avait bon la sueur la mairie bonjour
bonjour sacha bonjour à tous mes amis
d'avignon je vais attendre des amis
d'avignon tu vois que tu peux parler à
la peur
bon ça va bien ça nous chante une
chanson le noël de la rue
ses vents et le vent debout
c'est plaisant
dans le milieu
hu
derrière la vitrine à niveau tous
niveaux
[Musique]
je dirais tu as un visage parfait
elle est toujours aussi évasif je
voudrais remercier souvent les artistes
en j'ai eu la chance d'avoir comme sacha
et d'autres artistes disent tellement
sacha distel à mes côtés et je suis
parti en lever de rideau dans son
spectacle et je trouve que c'est très
bien parce que j'avais tout à apprendre
quand on débute à juste titre mon
manière dont j'ai interprété trois
chansons et sasha était là à 9 heures du
soir pourrait être à mes côtés pour
manger pour nous donner des conseils et
vraiment je souhaite à tous les artistes
d'avant un sa charge un ace et daniel
fait lever de rideau de jul ça va être
un truc aux états unis qui a fait plus
d'audience à la télévision mireille
mathieu dans un talk show où le tout
dernier épisode de la série des experts
las vegas
les experts les experts est mature ni
rien alors les experts ça fait douze
millions de téléspectateurs et mirail à
la réunion elle a réuni plus de 50
millions d'américains à la devant leur
télé en 1966 alors rendez compte 50
millions non ouais c'est les vingt deux
chiens exactement elle sur les vingt
deux shows france qui a vendu le plus de
disques
mireille mathieu ou mon autre ami michel
polnareff que j'aimerais aussi que
naples
le million mireille et michel 5 il fait
partie des plus gros vendeurs aussi qui
a vendu le plus de disques dans le monde
mireille mathieu oublions de ses
batteries jusqu'au beyoncé oui
beyoncé l'a vomi en ca vendu 100
millions sans fin de 2010 122 me c'est
bien beyoncé
je ne connais pas je tenais plus lady
gaga comme by lady gaga ouais elle est
super c'est une contrainte mission sur
la rencontre
heinig je peux du site et les murs en
posture j'adore cette émission et
j'adore ses filles c'est à vous bah oui
mais elle faisait les missions de ces
tabous nous moi j'ai recommencé le
direct on se rencontrait en ai dit mais
pourquoi on changerait pas la vie en
rose tout tout tout les deux pourquoi
pas et j'espère qu'on va pouvoir le
faire parce qu'elle est très bien j'aime
beaucoup à faire pour surfer sur la la
la la la la la la la
ah là là là
[Musique]
et franchement mireille mathieu et lady
gaga sont les ans vient du haut ont fait
un like the way lady je sais que tu nous
regardes ide eloga nous ici on a lady
gaga voilà donc voilà si tu veux venir
les 10 c'est toujours la bienvenue et
enfin non mais c'est vrai et mireille je
voudrais dire un truc l'aller je vous
dis les gens moi j'adore votre coupe de
cheveux
non franchement et vous n'avez jamais
changé de tout ça c'est la classe ne
peut ne pas aimer
moi j'adore mais j'ai une opportunité
pour les chaudes et carpentier stryges
angers de faire des têtes différentes
je sais pas j'ai tout fait tout fait
mais je me sens bien dans celle là on ne
peut pas me disent on ne peut aimer ou
ne pas aimer mais moi j'ai beau dire hey
je me sens bien elles seront béton s'il
on va pas changer
tu es parti sur l'autoroute du succès
moi je vais tenir montre moi j'étais
c'était ta coiffure qui m'avait rendu
amoureux de toi ouais j'aimais bien sûr
c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai je kiffe
les le reste non mais la koala le visage
un visage parfait magnifique soirée
glamour les yeux le nez la bouche rien
ajouter change pas sur ma me orane à la
maison toi qui fais ça
trouvez pas ça s'avérait chanter le
premier et regarde un mot danon et là
mon père est très différent de la missa
pro prenne sous les bras